ist ein fahnenfan sein Favorit ist die
deutsche Reichskriegsflagge
Griesser nennt sich Putin mit Nachnamen
und wie so oft in Russland weiß man
nicht ob das ein Zufall ist griechischer
ist 17 Schüler und fasziniert von der
Vergangenheit seine Mutter hat dem
Interview zugestimmt seinen Vater kennt
er nicht aber wir gehen die prigosin
kannte griechischer persönlich
ich spüre eine tiefe Trauer er war
während der spezialoperation für viele
Russen sowas wie ein Vater geworden
etwas zerbrochen
im Schatten Stalins spielt griechischer
Krieg er ist ein Streamer er spielt
Computerspiele und stellt das live ins
Internet manchmal geht er dafür sogar
ins Gebäude der wagnergruppe
griechischer sagt dass er kein Geld
dafür bekommt überprüfen können wir das
nicht im Spiel erobert griechischer die
Ukraine hier verschwimmen Wunsch und
Wirklichkeit auch Polen hat Grieser
platt gemacht
[Musik]
dann werden wir selbstverständlich mit
Atomwaffen darauf antworten
[Musik]
und wir werden unbedingt bis Warschau
kommen
es gibt verschiedene Szenarien alles
hängt von deinem Können ab und davon wie
sich der Gegner verhält
wir sind in St Petersburg einst erbaut
als Russlands Tor zur Europa
[Musik]
heute Heimat der Putins der prigos ins
und der wagnergruppe doch St Petersburg
zählt zu den schönsten Städten der Welt
vor den Firmen sitzt der wagnergruppe
tragen seit Tagen Sympathisanten ihre
Trauer
die Verunsicherung ist groß was wirklich
passiert ist Held steht dort geschrieben
meiner Meinung nach war das ein Mord und
kein Unfall aber wir werden das wohl nie
erfahren
das war doch kein zufälliges Ereignis
Flugzeuge explodieren doch nicht einfach
so im Himmel
irgendwem hat das genutzt wem das ist
unklar
kommt abends mit seiner Mutter hierher
zu diesem Zeitpunkt ist Rico Sinn noch
nicht begraben noch stellt sich die
Frage wie die Beerdigung aussehen soll
für den den man im Westen
Kriegsverbrecher nennt und hier die
Hoffnung Russlands Max
eine würdige Beisetzung
seinen Helden Russland
doch es kommt anders nach einem
verwirrspül- und falschen Fährten wird
Rico Sinn auf diesem Friedhof unter
Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit einfach
vergraben der Kremmel will keine Bilder
keine Sympathie warum
23 juni Rico sind bläst zum Marsch auf
Moskau und fordert Russlands führen
heraus doch erklärt um
danach präsentiert der Kreml Bilder wie
Trophäen von der Durchsuchung der
Büroräume falsche Pässe Goldbarren
Waffen Perücken sogar ein Foto des
gefallenen Helden in Unterwäsche
das Ziel war die Menschen zu
demoralisieren und ihr Vertrauen in ihn
zu untergraben die Zustimmung für ihn
ist gesunken im Vergleich zu den Monaten
vor dem Putsch das alles diente der
Vorbereitung um ihn später möglichst
geräuschlos liquidieren zu können
doch Rico sind fühlt sich sicher
erscheint rehabilitiert wird wieder in
den Kreml und zum afrika-gipfel geladen
bis der Absturz kommt
auch die Mafia vor wenn sie Komplizen
loswerden würden
das ist wie in Hollywood im Film Der
Pate der seine Hand lange ausradiert die
in unserem Fall viele Geheimnisse des
Putin Regimes mit ins Grab nehmen
am Firmen sitzt der Berg in der Gruppe
treffen wir Victoria sie hat die
Gedenkstätte mit organisiert ihr Mann
kämpft bei Wagner wenn sie von prikosin
und ihrer Gott spricht dann nennt sie
die bei einem alten Namen dem vom
letzten großen Krieg
er ist ein Petersburger ein lenin-grader
wir haben das immer gewusst er hat so
viel getan für unser Leningrad
am Abend lädt uns Victoria zu sich nach
Hause ein
auch in ihrer Wohnung lebt die
Geschichte die der Sowjetunion der guten
Zeiten wie Victoria sagt hier sammelt
sie spenden die sie an die Front schickt
wie es mit dem Krieg den
siegerechtfindet und mit Wagner
weitergeht das weiß sie nicht
und sagen dass man Wagner auflösen wird
andere dass sie ihre Tätigkeiten
fortsetzen können denn sie werden doch
gebraucht aber am Ende wird das kommen
wie es kommen muss
St Petersburg atmet Geschichte die viele
unterschiedlich sehen
[Musik]
hier lebten die Zaren hier wurden sie
gestürzt
hier trafen sich auch einst Putin und
brigo Sinn in diesen Tagen schreibt
Russland ein neues Kapitel seiner
Geschichte dessen Ende auch heute in St
Petersburg niemand kennt
[Musik]